ni
紙が1枚あります
これを
こうして
病院の窓から
投げると
だいたい
叱られます
もし褒められることがあるとしたら
多分精神病棟の方かな
パワー今
今日も元気だねぇ
注射を打ってねーよね
あの私40年ぐらい前に
病院に入院して
おりましたん
同じようにですね神しかないというかまぁ目の前何もないんですよね
することがないんで
クソ腹たっても窓から投げておりました
そうすると
看護婦さんが伊豆に来て
やめてもらえませんかあのにはに
ゴミをしないでください
お庭にね
にはに
に1を超えればいいんだと
そう解釈させていただきまして
これは吠えるためには何をするかというと
ゴンこれじゃダメだなやっぱ飛行機だよな
換気口
これでいこう
ということで試行錯誤の上
神好きーでとにかくにはを
病院の庭を超えるためのですね
torso のトライを何度もしたわけですね
そのたびごとに惹かれるんですけれどもついに
完全たるその純然たる神後期
燦然と紙飛行機がこの病院の庭を超えていく飛行機が出来ました
民家から苦情が来まして
あの隊員は早まりましたそれでは
隊員というより追い出されたという方が近いかもしれませんがん
大学にやっぱり返って何とか大学をですね卒業したいと思ったんですけれども
ほとんど描画のアパートで
寝ている日々がですね
続きましたあの本当に天井木目がですねもうほんと毎日なんですけれども
天井を見ててもう組ばっかり見て
そのうちそれが木目がですねだんだん
宇宙銀河系に見えてくるんですねこれちょっと終わりが近いかなと思うんですけども
その
そこで考えたのはですねその宇宙から地球に向かってもし紙飛行機を飛ばしたらどう
なるんだろうかと
要素おかしいですけども
その
だいたい終えると皆さん思うんでしょうけど私はそのときに不思議と思えないんじゃ
ないかなと思ったんです
なぜかというと
急に大気圏突入するときに行為空気のところにゾーンと来るわけじゃなくてだんだん水
と頃からだんだん行為空気のところに来るそうすると
空気ブレーキがかかる紙飛行機神のほうがいいな
で
膨らんでる風船ちょっと膨らんでる要するに空気ブレーキかかるほうがいいな
そういうふうに思いまして立体的な紙飛行機を作るべきたというふうに思いました
1000種類を超える上沖公共ですね
黙々と前にですね寝たい寝てちょっと来ては紙飛行機を折ってという毎日でした
ac ん
500機を超えたぐらいですかね種類を超えたぐらいのところで断端金は買ってきて
ついにですね
立体的なスペースシャトル形の紙国旗が出来ました
その飛行機ですちょっと
追ってみたいと思います
ん
バッハ
持っています
4日
ありません
通り紙飛行機なんで
あの
鋏は使いませんん
1枚の紙で通るだけでですね
作ります
4日
ございます
蹴りを入れてます
ています
立体的にですね仕上げていきます
バッハ
と思っています
美味しい
初ん
ています
ああああああああ
はいっ
飛ばしてみたいと思います
すみません皆さんところもしかして墜落する場合もあるので
ヘッド保険かけてますかね大事ですか
いきます
321いいローン
4日 ten
なら10点ですね
70点で一番向こうまで持って行きたかったんですけれども
8まあこうやって1判の紙にこだわって
いろんな表記をつくっていくんですが
いろんなその私の体も治って
何所で神国旗の指導したりする時にパさんはある
紙飛行機では
一番ですよねって言われるんですが
いやー一番孤独果てて言ったら
いや一番だと言ってくださいうから
一番ですけどと言ってしまってですね
一番ということになるとですね
さっきの飛行機ですねちょっというのがせました
あれ
作ってから35年経って今 jaxa のごね認可されて宇宙から本当に
地区に買って飛ばすという
認可を得ました
あとやるだけです
来月はのなさの方にいきますので
nasa の方にこれを宇宙から飛ばすんだということになっており言う言うことにし
てもおります
見事ですね皆さんの説得ができるかどうかですね
頑張っていきたいと思うんですが
宇宙の話より今度はそのお父さんはその殺気とう
世界一って何だろうなぁということでベゼル世界一になるしてもらいんでしょうけど
まあ言いがかり上一番だって言ってしまったもんで
また映像が後から出るからっ
これあの宇宙からさっきの飛行機ですね
真花
東大の航空中の数値先生によってタイパの風洞実験掃除の外へて
マッハ7耐えました
これすごいあの全ての国カーブ差しになったと思うんですが
紙飛行機がまあ端に耐えたということで
これでいけるというふうに思っています
まだ覇者戻ってきますけど
あの
やっぱ世界一ってギネスじゃないかなぁと
でいろんな種類があるんですが
あのたった滞空時間じゃないか
でそのときの滞空時間のに熱記録が27.6病なんです
たいしたことないぞボンゴでしょ
10秒を超えると大体髪コキ大会優勝できるんです
10秒って長いんです
で当時20秒以上飛ばせる人は世界でパッた2人しかいます
一人が20点5秒腕壊して投げれない
そして1位の人が自分全損27.6秒
トンデモない記録なんですよ猫
100m を8秒台で走るぐらいの感覚なんでもうちょっとほんとかっていうぐらいの
広くなんです実は
で私は19秒しか飛ばせてないんですね
でまずやることは一つ当時体重が82キロ
痩せなきゃいけない
体が重いとですねやっぱり飛ばせないんでそれと紙飛行機の研究ですね
同じ紙なら
翼が広いが多いです
当然ゆっくりと思いますよね
ただし
広く作ると強度がなくなりますので高く上げれないんです
それで高く上げるためにはまず神
強い髪を選ぶということそれから投げ方
あのにグラムしかないので
一生懸命腕立て伏せ腹筋にあるといいですね余計飛ばなくなります
やったことはホテルとかなんかにいつも仕事でホテルなくいる時にはティッシュ
ペーパーを上に投げたりですねやって結果的に行き着いたのは格闘技
の足なんです普通距離競技の時はこう思ってこう投げます
距離競技会これです対空になると今度は右足が
右足が前
剣道とかこういうはそして大きく
しゃがんで真上を目指して釣竿にあるなった自分で
バー嫉妬を向けるとそうだいた=6
あの騎士ガイ pict 面痛いんですけど
このを
やり方で
ギネスを超えました映像があ
映るかな
はい今
投げませ
吉川統合
次は
どこにある何をしよういうことであの時々あの色の世界もあった時に子供たちの教え
てー
神呼吸をしているんですが
ネパールに子供たちに教えて
25と10年前のことなんですけど行ったことがあります
でちょっと時間があったので山に
ノボ高い山に登ってそこから
飛ばしてやろうと思ったんですが
写真のようにですね
実はこの写真の前なんですけど兵隊に
リストを付けられまし突きつけられてですね
何しに来たと
紙ヒコーキを
というちょうどあのネパール当時内戦状態で
そこはあの反政府軍のアジトをだったんですね
それを知らずに入って迷い込んで
普通殺されます
で
紙飛行機飛ばしたという飛ばしに来たと言った時点で
貸家ツアー同省からもう殺しちゃうかとかいう感じなんですけど
かみかみありますからちょっと行き飛ばすのを待ってくださいねということで今震え
ながら今撮っている写真ですこれ
鳥羽なんだ同署という感じでで飛んだ
どんどんありがたかった
でこれは後正体も仲間にしなきゃいけないお前の飛ばせ
お前もとましてあげお前あなたも飛ばしたらどうです
そして飛ばしてみんながこうやって見守っているところですね
俺も飛ばして
戦争なんてしちゃいけねえよなということで
っていいよなぁというまあこういう空気がこの写真です立ってくると思いますね
あの本当に
紙飛行機には
平和の空が似合います
皆さんも
ジェヒカミコ今日って
相当に出て思いっきり飛ばしてください
終わります